this is weird
we came in peace
for all your cash
hey guys pete here for all mankind is
back and today i'll be talking about the
season 3 premiere i was kind of mixed on
it there were some things i liked and
some things i didn't but it definitely
had its moments it was tense it was fun
to catch up with the characters years
later and there are a lot of interesting
details to parse as we skip forward into
the 90s in this alternate timeline i'll
be getting into everything that happened
and what i think about it right after
this quick spoiler warning if you
haven't watched episode 1 of for all
mankind's third season then this video
won't be for you and with that out of
the way let's get into it the thing that
pulled me into for all mankind's orbit
is this idea that history could be
drastically different if just a few key
events happen differently the main event
here is that the space race never ended
and that led to a series of changes that
managed to produce a reality that's more
hopeful than the one we're currently
living in i thought the closing shot of
this episode really encapsulated that
perfectly you have the wonders of space
and watching the sun rise as it comes
out from behind earth you have the
heroism from dany's actions that's
necessary in so many of these high
stress situations and you have the
fragility of it all as he suspended at
the end of that tether it's the
fragility of the positive changes in
this timeline the fragility of the
characters who are getting older and the
fragility of keeping things together in
a show that skips a decade in between
seasons episode 1 opens with a montage
catching us up on all that's happened in
between just like season two did because
this is all so crucial to how the story
is constructed i'll be doing a full
breakdown of the changes from our
timeline later this week that'll give me
a little time to watch all the minisodes
they added on apple tv that fill in the
gaps and read up some on the real events
that happened in our timeline the big
points that affect our understanding of
this episode are that gary hart avoided
his sex scandal and became the president
in 1984 after reagan completed his
second term in this timeline he's
re-elected in 1988 while ellen wilson is
elected as a republican senator in texas
in 1986. this sets up a race between her
and bill clinton in the opening year of
season 3
1992. this is when clinton became
president in our timeline but ellen is
the girl who caught the tank so it'll be
interesting to see just how much people
love astronauts in the show's timeline
things continue to develop at an
accelerated pace and there are mentions
of the new character deb iesa and his
partner richard hilliard making a
game-changing discovery related to clean
nuclear energy they've mastered nuclear
fusion which is a lot cleaner than the
fission technology we use in our
timeline but impractical due to
helium-3's rarity but then we also
learned that they discovered that to be
in abundance on the moon their company
will partner with nasa to mine it and we
see that this shift has drastically
reduced global warming karen partnered
with sam to start a space tourism
industry and danny stevens has followed
in his parents footsteps to become an
astronaut the focus on the continued
space race has been good for the soviet
union instead of collapsing they're
thriving under gorbachev who implemented
a hybrid socialist market economy their
influence is spreading throughout the
western hemisphere and now includes
mexico right on the u.s border space
travel is expanding to more countries
including india and china who have
aspirations for their own moon base and
north korea who scrapped a ballistic
missile program to focus on space in the
show's present we find karen baldwin on
the space hotel ship in orbit that her
company polaris belt which is where
episode 1 gets its name she gets a call
from her business partner sam who was
tracy's second husband after gordo who
we saw karen sell the outpost to at the
end of last season they're there getting
ready for the first group of guests to
arrive
and the commercial space tourism
industry is prepared to take its next
leap forward
after the credits there's another
installment in the margot waking up and
getting ready for work in her office
series this is how we met margot back in
1969 and in each new season we see that
her hard work is at least getting her a
more comfortable place to crash here in
1992 it becomes apparent that because
the show skips through time it has to
front load a lot of details into this
sequence to try to bring us up to speed
also margot has been working for nasa
for 30 years and she'll have been at jsc
for more or less that long before the
season ends so they have to introduce
new characters like the assistant who
emma is training margot is now the
director of nasa and it feels like this
will be the last season for her
generation of characters to be the
center of attention we get a quick look
at updated tech here as well she has a
flat panel display showing the mission
status board and nori has an apple pda
that looks much more advanced than the
newton message pad that existed at that
time but never really caught on in her
briefing we learned that debbayesa is
trying to curry favor with her and that
a north korean rocket has exploded in
orbit inside mars mission control we
learn that bill has become a flight
director and that they're testing a new
nuclear rocket engine on the moon it's
not working and if they can't fix it
they'll miss the 96 mars launch window
elena's on the project and she's going
to have to figure this out and we learn
later that she'll have to go to the moon
to try to apply her fix in person we
also learned that her father is now back
in the u.s living with her and her
husband and their son margot and her
staff also learned that russia has
announced that they're going to mars in
96 and her pal sergey delivers the party
line on tv saying that they'll be the
first to get there from that
announcement we learned that there's
pressure on margot to name their
commander which has come down to a
choice between danielle poole and ed
baldwin molly cobb is still the head of
the astronaut office and she appears to
have adjusted to losing her eyesight
margot tries to press her to announce
danielle as the mars commander but she's
leaning towards ed this disagreement
highlights the ways nasa is changing and
molly still thinks that someone with a
test pilot background like ed is the
better choice a little bit later margot
goes to pick up a record that her
assistant gave her a message about and
we learned that this is a code for her
to contact sergey he asked her for some
help and we learned that they've been
secretly helping each other over the
years he brings up this year's iac
conference which gives them a chance to
show that they have this affection for
each other and reminds us of the closing
moments of season 2 when the kgb was
watching his call to her she walks away
from the phone smiling thinking about
this conference and he gets a follow-up
call from his handlers telling him to
put more pressure on her to help them
with their nuclear engine which makes it
sound like they've announced this trip
to mars but they're not quite ready ed
and danny are both visiting the polaris
hotel for danny stevens wedding their
competition for the mars commander job
is lively and we see that they've both
been remarried and are traveling with
their significant others danny stevens
does marry his girlfriend amber and the
first ever wedding in space which turns
out to be pretty uncomfortable we learn
a lot of little details here like he's
gotten sober after his parents death
jimmy stevens makes things pretty
awkward with his best man speech where
he makes some accusations against nasa
we find out that kelly is a research
scientist in antarctica rather than a
pilot but we don't really get many more
details there and then things get really
uncomfortable when in the first dance
with his wife danny plays the version of
don't be cruel that he danced to with
karen when they were first starting
their affair this understandably freaks
karen out and i'm not sure what he was
going for here because everything had
been pointing to the fact that he'd
moved on and was pretty happy in this
new relationship we don't get to learn
anything more about it though because a
piece of debris from the north korean
rocket explosion hits one of the polaris
thrusters and that causes it to do an
uncommanded burn
this sets up an intense situation where
the gravity continues to increase and
things get worse when they send two
people out to do a repair and they get
killed after a cable breaks loose that
wreaks havoc on the ship as it thrashes
around and when they try to evacuate
everyone through the elevators sam is
killed ed injures his leg and things are
looking dire for anyone to be able to
get from the ring to the shuttles under
this amount of gravity the only path out
is to use an emergency access shaft
which is essentially a ladder and
thinking about trying to climb up that
at 2 g's your body feels like it weighs
twice as much and that just keeps going
up because ed is injured danny gets his
chance to be the hero and in a thrilling
sequence he goes out and is able to shut
the thruster down i thought this looked
fantastic and i mean i didn't really
think everyone was gonna die here but it
felt a little strange like it didn't
feel like danny had been developed as
this super astronaut or whatever we're
supposed to accept that he is here and i
suppose that's just part of what happens
when we have to jump over this large
period of time like if i compare this to
the season 2 premiere i really felt
something when molly left that lava tube
and went into the radiation to try to
save wubbo but as i mentioned i really
like that closing scene and it gets you
excited for all of the space stuff you
know is sure to come throughout the rest
of the season not a bad beginning a
pretty impressive set piece to close it
out but i do think it does raise some
concerns for the future i am a sucker
for all the alternate timeline stuff and
the ripple effects from the space race
continuing and i've grown attached to
the original cast of characters that
said it feels like they should be aging
out and i was surprised that we haven't
seen piscotty and sally ride or any of
the side characters from jamestown who
were all right there to help them
transition into the next generation
danny and jimmy stevens have this tragic
story related to gordo and tracy and
kelly could develop into a character in
her own right but it doesn't feel like
they could replace the originals based
on where we're at right now of course
the race to mars is on and there's tons
of potential there and we do know this
show generally gets better as things
progress both seasons have gone out with
amazing endings and i expect that this
one will too i think my biggest takeaway
re-watching them to get ready for this
is that the series does some things that
don't always work getting there but most
of it at least makes sense after they
deliver a properly dramatic climax of an
ending i think aleda is a pretty good
example of this in the first season a
lot of her firebug stuff felt so
disconnected from the main story but now
when i see her father is back living
with her as she's starting a family and
then i hear she's going to the moon it
all turns out to be the most emotionally
charged parts of this episode i hope
that karen and danny stuff eventually
make sense too i get that karen was
fairly unlikable and truly unhappy in
the first season and she went on this
path of self-discovery when you're
becoming something else it's very human
to make mistakes i mean that's sort of
what a midlife crisis is it just feels
so unnecessarily unsettling in their
connection to shane and danny's
childhood i feel like if gordo were
still around and had an affair with
kelly or if danielle poole had an affair
with kelly it would be equally
unsettling and they were never taking
care of her as a child because her
parents were off being astronauts i
don't want to go on about it but it
really took the air out of the episode
when he played the song because i'm
thinking this guy is set up to be the
potential future of the series and he
just feels like a reminder of one of the
worst turns the writers have made so
again i hope it does make sense that
they get into some of the nitty gritty
of what's behind it all rather than
treating it like it's just the thing
that happened that he can't let go of
and i do hope we get to see the new
character step up and fill the old one's
shoes because these really do have to be
their last missions on the other end ed
and danny's rivalry was a lot of fun and
some of the gravity stuff when what
feels like his soon-to-be second ex-wife
tries to throw her shoe at him and the
bride and groom on the wedding cake that
was all funny technically speaking the
space walk stuff looked great while
trying to make the cast look older
wasn't quite as effective i can mostly
overlook that though it was unconvincing
but not really distracting i like the
undercurrent of nasa changing and it
seems more autonomous than it was with
the dod in-house at the beginning of
season two we see that they're still
there but it didn't feel like they were
setting up the new general to be as
involved with margot's day-to-day like
bradford was
i hope this is an indication that we
won't have guns on the moon part 2 and
there's something new and exciting
happening on the red planet one detail
that i couldn't shake was that the
ending of season 2 shows someone
standing on mars in 1995
which indicates that the dates will get
pushed up that makes the nerva engine
stuff feel more critical and makes you
wonder how sergey and his team will get
ready if they're having trouble with
their engine and i didn't mention it
before but margot's situation seems
really concerning you can kind of see
how she's trying to do what's best for
humanity overall but it doesn't feel
like it's going to end well overall the
race does sound exciting and i'm anxious
to see what happens when they get to
mars i speculated on that some in my
trailer breakdown and there wasn't much
here to expand on that yet for all my
nitpicks i'm confident that this will be
an enjoyable season there's plenty to
like in this opening episode and i have
faith that things will fall into place i
think that's probably a good place to
leave things let me know in the comments
what you thought about the premiere what
you think about the trajectory of this
season so far and check back because i
will be doing a detailed breakdown of
all the alternate timeline changes
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon